foreign
memories of them are from about five to
eight years old of them being together
and these memories include them fighting
name calling ghost being screaming and
yelling at each other basically I notice
I have the same tendency with my family
today and even my girlfriend oh man
[Music]
good morning good afternoon good night
what's up this is John with Dr John
deloney's show
hey this is a show helping you figure
out what in the world is going on with
your marriage what's going on with your
kids what's going on with the world
around you your mental health your
physicals whatever's going on in your
life that's what this show is for
we're helping millions of people get
their lives back their marriage is back
get their kids back
get their bodies and Minds working again
and we are here for you so thank you so
much for joining us if you want to be on
the show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask
and I want to particularly thank our
sponsors with Thorne t-h-o-r-n-e the
best supplements on the planet what I've
been taking me and my family have been
taking for years go to thorn.com
youth just a letter deloney that's
thorn.com you slash deloni and we have
jacked it up 25 off everything
everything and that's our gift to you uh
we want you to get the supplements you
need great quality stuff uh world-class
supplements
um from a world-class company at a great
great price all right let's go out to uh
Utah and talk to brother Ryan what's up
Ryan
hello John how are you doing today I'm
doing great man how about you
I'm doing really well excellent
excellent what's up
well today
with a question I'm wondering uh how do
I eliminate unhealthy emotionally
charged behaviors in my relationships
with my family and significant others
when I'm hurt and frustrated cool man
how old are you
uh I'm 21. 21.
what's emotional charge what does that
look like in real life
well I want to give you a little bit of
background on this okay so
uh when I was eight years old my parents
ended up splitting up that means my
memories of them are from about five to
eight years old of them being together
and these memories include them fighting
name-calling goats being screaming and
yelling at each other and that's you
know what I learned to be normal
and um basically I noticed I have the
same tendency with my family today and
even my girlfriend
and I just you know these these were my
normal
relationship uh situations and so how do
I fix that
oh man
how how much honesty can you handle
today
uh I think I can handle a lot a little
bit or a lot or like are you if if I lay
it on pretty good will we still be
friends
I'm open to it yes okay
um you mentioned the word tendency a lot
I want to throw that word out and never
use it again okay your parents
um beat each other up physically and
metaphorically I mean in in
psychologically and emotionally okay
that happened you saw all of that
and you also even at a young age knew
that's not right it scared you
it's all the only picture you had but
you knew it wasn't right
and so I want to fast forward to your 21
year old you're an adult
and screaming and yelling and carrying
on and being over emotional with someone
that you care about with anybody much
less your girlfriend
I want to take Mom and Dad out now
okay I don't want to continue to call
back to well this is just I know it's
just a tendency I have no you're
screaming and yelling and being abusive
to your girlfriend stop
is that fair
I think so yes
okay I know so tell me why you're
struggling because you know this hurts
her you don't feel good after you're
done screaming and hollering and acting
the fool why do you continue to do it
what does it get you
uh you know it doesn't get me anywhere
and it hurts me too but in the moment it
just feels so natural I guess it gets
you something what is it
otherwise you wouldn't keep doing it
um
I guess that puts me in a position of
power over her sometimes okay
and that keeps you from feeling small
and little and scared like that
five-year-old little boy was when Mom
and Dad were screaming and smashing
things
does your girlfriend deserve to be
treated like this
no she doesn't anybody I want to change
it nobody does okay
your parents cannot change your
situation in the present so let's stop
talking about them we know we've done
the tracing we know where it's from and
now he's got to come to the present how
um
how in are you on making a change here
I'm in
100 percent
it's hard
because power is a a really really
um seductive mistress
like if you told me you wanted to quit
lying or quit uh cheating or quit like
man that's easier than
turning off the addiction to this
temporary feeling of power and strength
yes for sure
so here's what we're going to do we're
going to create a new identity starting
right this second okay
from this point forward Ryan is a guy
who never yells
Ryan is a guy who never screams who's
never emotionally abusive that's not the
kind of guy you are that's not who you
are those are things that you never do
say it
I will never do those things
you're talking now see you skipped a
step you went straight to actions I
don't want I want identity
I'm a guy who fill in the blank use your
own words not mine
I'm a guy who loves people and treats
them well nope because I you can love
people and treat them well and also lose
your mind and throw temper tantrum and
scream in y'all
who are you
who are you gonna be from this point
forward
I guess someone who no no no guessing
say it car ramrod say it
I'm a guy who's gonna take care to make
sure I'm mindful of people's emotions
and take care of my own self oh my gosh
could you say it anymore like me Ryan
I'm a guy who does not scream at anybody
ever
I'm a guy that doesn't scream at people
I'm a guy who doesn't ever raise his
voice because I'm not a child
I'm a man who will not screamed because
I'm not a child anymore okay
I'm a man who will love my
girlfriend my future wife I love my kids
with a deep respect
I'm never going to take that from them
by trying to be overly powerful you
don't have to say all that but you get
what I'm saying this is going to take an
entire identity change because if you
just try to change actions what you're
going to do is what most dads do
most husbands do most boyfriends do and
you're just gonna Channel it somewhere
else
what do I mean by that
instead of screaming and yelling and
being all angry
you're gonna just
bury it deep inside your chest like a
nuclear reactor and everyone in the
house is going to know you're in a bad
mood but you're not going to say
anything
and then if she says are you okay what's
wrong you're going to get all mad why
are you always bothering me about me
being in a bad mood I'm fine you're the
one that keeps nagging me see what I'm
saying it's the same exact thing one is
just done with silence and one is done
with volume
so we're not going to focus so much
right this second on just doing a couple
of things differently we're going to
change Who We Are
and that starts with a proclamation I
will never yell at a person again if
that means in the middle of a fight or
middle of a disagreement or I feel it
welling up inside of me I'm gonna look
at her and say I need five minutes and
you just Sprint out the front door and
go for a walk
that's what you're gonna do
that means you drop and do 20 push-ups
if that means you take a knee and you
say will you hold my hand that means if
you say no more talking I need I need we
need to finish this tomorrow
because I'm a guy who never yells
so like one of my core like I'm a guy
who doesn't borrow money I just don't
borrow money
and so hey we need this thing well we're
not gonna get this thing we have to
figure out another way to do it I'm
gonna have to go sell something I'm
gonna have fill in the blank I'm gonna
have to take out another job I'm gonna
have to take another shift I might take
another speaking gig because I'm a guy
who doesn't borrow money so that means
I've got to figure out another Avenue
I've taken it completely off the table
so that's the level of of identity shift
okay so that's number one number two you
have to decide I'm gonna catch myself
when the feelings begin and I'm gonna
take myself out of that situation I'm
gonna ask myself
what is my body trying to protect me
from I can almost guarantee you your
body is trying to protect you from
feeling powerless ever again because you
felt it when you were a kid and you
never want to feel it again am I right
or wrong
correct yeah
part of being in a relationship is
sometimes being
um the feeling small it's part of it
and the way to rebalance the power or
the the not the power the way to
rebalance your relationship is not
ripping somebody else down by their hair
and bringing them down below you that's
not it sometimes it's just standing up
you get that
so give me give me play it out for me
play out the scenario
um what what's the last when's the last
time you yelled and screamed and found
yourself just in a rage what happened
I don't know like something happened
recently that's what you're calling
right
it's been a little it's been a little
while but um yeah I guess I guess a
situation that I have is like
um
I was uh we're gonna clean up her car
right and um
she had another option from one of her
friends who was gonna go to help her but
she wasn't like figuring it out and I
kind of just lost it I raised my voice I
didn't yell or anything I raised my
voice for sure
yeah I know so stupid what about it what
about that moment made you raise your
voice what were you trying to
communicate
I guess I was trying to say that I'm
trying to you know do something for her
um and when she has another option but
is not exploring it or trying to help me
with that
I was like I feel like I don't know what
to do and that was my first response was
to raise my voice and get frustrated
I don't think your first response is to
raise your voice to get frustrated with
her I think your first response is to
raise your voice so that you can get
those that your mom and your dad to look
at you
well somebody please look at me because
I'm scared I'm hurting
and Mom and Dad chose other options
and so when your girlfriend has another
option your body just goes to Terror
mode and you have to learn to be an
adult and say
we were scared when we were five but now
I'm 21.
now I'm 22 now I'm 30 and I'm 40. I
don't kick and scream like a child
anymore I acknowledge whoa
whenever she has another option it makes
me feel uncomfortable it makes me feel
less than man
yelzers
I need to choose enough to to work on
that to not feel like that I need to
reach back out and say hey you have a
million options I'd love to help you
with your car if you don't want me on
help that's great I'm gonna go do
something else
that's you choosing peace not choosing
War
you get the difference
yes sir
do you want that
of course I want that I've got some
buddies that just love chaos they just
love it man like they're content to die
like just in chaos and I don't
understand it I'm I'm just always
wanting more and more peaceful life
um
here's the thing that's worked for me
when I feel my body taken off on me I
literally will take my open hand and put
it on my chest
I'll take a deep breath and I will ask
myself what is my body trying to protect
me from
it is almost never it's almost never my
wife it's almost never my kids
it's almost always a feeling of I'm
feeling powerless I'm feeling less than
I'm feeling not important
and that's my issue not theirs
that's my issue not theirs
sounds like you spent a long time a lot
of years
blaming your late teen and early
adulthood behaviors and actions and
choices on your parents let's don't do
that anymore
as Jocko says let's take full ownership
let's take extreme ownership I'm Ryan
I'm 21 years old I'm an adult I'm old
enough to buy beer
from this point forward I'm a guy who
treats people with dignity and respect
never raises his voice because only
children raise their voice unless
they're trying to keep somebody from
falling off a bridge or getting hit by a
car or something
I don't raise my voice it's not who I am
it's not how I solve problems
and I'm a guy that when my body starts
to take off on me I feel it
and I own it and by the way this is just
me being vulnerable and honest
on Sunday
man I was grumpy I wasn't feeling I was
just feeling low just like a bum
um
like son and I
um I my daughter got a trampoline for
Christmas and it's been sitting in the
garage I haven't had time to fix it and
my son has been asking me can we get
that up can we get that up and I wanted
to I wanted a break
my son comes bebopping and Dad can we
put up the trampoline today and I was
like you know what fine let's just do it
now he's like and he said whoa it's okay
Dad we don't have to do it today he knew
it he could feel it on me I was like no
you keep asking let's just get this done
we went outside and I was grumpy we got
it done I never raised my voice I never
yelled never got mad but I was I was a
nuclear reactor
and then yesterday was Monday
my son got home from school and he was
walking through like Hey Dad and I just
said hold on come here come here come
here
he said what happened and he kind of
froze like he was in trouble and I said
hey you are not in trouble and I grabbed
both sides of his face with my hands and
I held his face and I said yesterday I
was really just in a mood had nothing to
do with you that was about me
one of my favorite things about you is
you kept kept asking hey Dad can we do
something together can we do something
together can we do something together
can we build this thing because I know
our family is going to love having
trampoline back out there
can we do this thing together thank you
for not giving up on me son
my grumpiness was about me not you I was
so fun getting to put that together with
you and he said thanks Dad and he went
to the next room I said I was sorry
you're gonna have to see your story a
lot Ryan because you're practicing a
whole new way of life let me tell you
every second of it is worth it put the
effort in
when you're 23 24 you're not gonna be
this guy anymore because you're gonna
have practice you can have worked on it
you're gonna grab grind scraped your
knuckles up you but you're gonna be a
guy who doesn't yell and scream you're
gonna be a guy who owns his feelings
treats people with dignity and respect
and it is the person you're gonna be the
person who changes the family curse
forever
it's not gonna be fun
let them be worth it we'll be right back
[Music]
I've got a word from our sponsor better
help listen I've been on both ends of
therapy in my life I've gotten it myself
and I've walked people through it and
I've seen the benefits from both sides
when someone owns their past and the
cracks in their armor but here's the
deal Getting to Know Yourself is not a
one-time event acknowledging the stories
that make you who you are can be a
lifelong process and talking through
things with the right sounding board
empowers you to change your future and
be the best version of yourself so if
you're thinking about starting therapy I
recommend better help better help
connect you with a licensed therapist
who can walk with you on that journey of
self-discovery and it's a hundred
percent online and it's designed to be
convenient flexible and work for your
schedule just fill out a quick
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and if it's not the
right fit you can switch therapists at
any time for no additional charge visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com
deloney
all right let's go to Laura in Spokane
Washington what's up Laura
um
how are you I'm I'm great life all right
y'all doing okay
um yeah shaking a little bit
oh good great film don't be shaking
I've got my feet on the ground I'm
taking deep breaths there you go perfect
perfect yeah what's up how can I help
um
which is I'm homesick for Hawaii
and
um a lot of people in my family
experience the same thing
um and I've been trying to handle it by
getting in touch with my community here
and
um just
you know uh sort of hustling to get
into the community and make friends and
uh it's difficult
here and there
um but the homesickness
it'll it'll set me into just depression
for on weekends at a time
um you've been feeling it for a decade
huh
yeah
all right I'm gonna ask you a crazy
question about homesickness okay
okay it's about 10 years ago how old are
you now
30. okay oh man perfect so tell me about
20 year old Laura who was she what was
she gonna be when she grew up what does
she want to do tell me about her
beautiful was she crazy when she always
making out with everybody like tell me
all about Laura oh my gosh no I
like this
um a 20 year old Laura moved to San
Francisco okay uh uh because she had a
dream of working in the film industry
okay which is something that didn't
exist essentially where it came from
um it's kind of known if you want to get
education you go to the mainland you go
seek it out and everyone said you can
always come back
but it's unaffordable
okay it's um practically impossible
um Laura
18.
um
oh gosh
so uh 18 year old Laura was
uh jumping into freshwater pools
uh going to the beach
uh having fun with all my buddies uh
just family
surrounded by Family his grandparents um
cousins brothers sisters
yep
um and uh my immediate family has all
moved with me along the way
except for my grandparents who are still
there
um and uh they always say that they're
the abandoned grandparents of course
grandparents are wonderful
um
um passport agents for guilt trips
yeah they're wonderful at that everybody
was born there exactly
two yeah
um most of the time
not always now let's I want to
categorize it like you're talking about
Hawaii okay so yeah
it's the most beautiful place on planet
Earth
can we agree on that
yes I was just hanging out with my
friends this weekend and they are from
Hawaii and just listening to them
discuss it it sounds magic I've never
been it sounds not real
yeah everything not real from like the
cleanliness of the air in certain parts
of the certain Islands to the PACE
everyone's just kind of a notch slower
to the food is so fresh like it was
swimming this morning and we're eating
it tonight like all of it to deep deep
family Roots like he was explaining to
me how this
this part of the family came over from
Japan this part
like
I want you to know leaving that is very
very real okay
okay that's that's number one you're not
crazy
the second thing here is a more general
statement of when I hear people talk
about their homesick they miss what
they're often telling me is they miss
the person they were before they left
ah I see and the environment was a
context but often so was the age
when you said 20 I was like yep
one of the coolest guys ever was 18 to
20 year old John that guy ruled because
he thought he ruled he was an idiot like
a punk skinny but he thought he
was awesome
and the rules didn't apply and he could
jump in pools and be silly and go on
dates that and so I'm homesickness for
I'm homesick for him in his Carefree
attitude in the possibilities that were
endless ahead of me
and I always think if I just go back to
that town and that place where I was I
can reclaim that and it never works out
because yeah because my John in his 40s
he goes with him
and that guy's tired has two kids been
married a long time you know what I mean
it's just it's it doesn't like my hair I
don't like my haircut like it's just
it's just the same right that guy that
guy goes with me
yeah
and so my question for you is
do you miss Hawaii do you miss your
family roots and do you have this deep
call to
get back to
um like a family Legacy that can be very
very real
and or
man do you miss that Laura that a whole
world was possibilities and you were
gonna go make it in the film that you
were going to be the one that got out
and went and did this wild stuff on the
mainland and then brought all this money
enjoy and excitement Fame back and now
your 30 year old Laura and you're like
got a job you got insurance right it's
yeah you missed that person is that what
it is
yeah I got my Barton nights and I have
two
oh my God
stay at home during the day take care of
them and the chores and then go to work
and uh serve uh a lot of people like to
bring their uh their problems to me too
so is there is there a sense that in
some ways now especially with two
toddlers especially with your service
job
you're living somebody else's life
I mean it feels like that sometimes
yeah I bet it feels like that a lot I
don't want to tell you how you're
feeling but I bet if you were honest
with yourself you would most of your
days spent making sure everyone else's
life is okay
yeah actually the other night I said
um you know if I wanted to work in
Hospitality I would have stayed on the
island
because you can make a hundred you know
a table a night yeah your tips would
have been way more right yeah yeah
here's what here's a third even wackier
on top of these two layers that I've
given you a third one
um it wasn't until like within a hundred
years
and especially it wasn't in until like
the last I don't know 30 or 40 maybe 50
years
that there were cameras everywhere and
videos everywhere and our brains have
some really remarkable built-in
um ways of slowly letting memories fade
and they take they move into our bodies
and they're not so acute and not so
painful we remember how we felt on the
beach but we don't remember like the
exact whatever they look like right
and now we have bypassed that and we go
back to it and go back to it and go back
to it we scan we scan we scan we look at
all photos we look at all photos we look
at old videos we look at new photos at
new videos we see you see new 18 year
old Laura's running around on Hawaii and
you remember you
you see what I'm saying so we've kind of
hacked our brains natural way of moving
on from heartache and from memories and
we keep dragging our our brain back
through the mud and be like yeah but
remember this and we keep bringing it
back up and it doesn't know what to do
because this is new technology right
and so we have all three of these things
here's my question for you
when's the last time you asked yourself
with with true honesty
what do I actually want with my one tiny
precious little life
I've been thinking about that a lot
lately lately
yeah
um I'm gonna tell you this and running
to a location probably won't give that
to you
okay it might it might maybe let me be
super clear it might
changing environments may be exactly
what you need
but my guess is uh or what I promise you
is if you pack up right today and you
move to Hawaii tomorrow and I gave you a
million dollars and you just you had no
money worries
30 year old Laura would go back to the
island
with your frustrations with your I
haven't grieved over the fact that I was
going to make it in the industry and I
got two little toddlers not a bad life a
great life in fact but just different
not what I not how I drew it up
I have to remind myself that on occasion
because it was not
I'm a freaking YouTuber now Laura that's
my job that's my job I was never in the
cards that wasn't the plan and here we
are right so sometimes I wanted to be I
was gonna be a college president that
was gonna be what I did and sometimes I
have to remind myself I I intentionally
chose a different track I went a
different way
and it's my life's gonna look very
different than it did and it's all good
it's all good it's gonna look different
right
so you've been asking yourself the
question what do you want
and I think
I think
I'm going in a positive direction
because I'm
I'm hustling really hard to get into
um
to helping others get their films made
out here oh my gosh you're the most
pragmatic mother of two stop being
pragmatist for a second what do you want
to do Laura
fast forward 36 months 36 months it's
very it's a blink of an eye
three years 36 months fast forward me
there where do you want to be what do
you want to be doing
okay that's that's a really tough
question no you have it right when I
said it it came right to you
you know exactly where you want to be
you just don't want to say it out loud
because you've said it before and it
didn't work out where do you want to be
helping my community oh my gosh it feels
I I feel like I want I want Community I
want more community
you want friends you want neighbors what
does that mean what does community mean
be very specific
um
but Dungeons and Dragons group okay okay
I knew it you're kind of weird and
you've got to be able to say that out
loud
yeah
actually yeah it's really funny
um it's not funny I mean I
I'm
I'm a weirdo yeah we all be a weirdo I
like to get together with my buddies and
watch grown men punch each other in the
face for money I like we watch fights
all the like that's insane it's dumb
that we do that and I do it every week I
do it all the time this weekend I'm
going to see a punk rock show I'm in my
40s I'm too old for this I'm going
anyway and I'm probably gonna get hurt
just like I did last time and it will be
worth it like we're all weird and you
look like that is right on that is right
on the level with me I am like punk rock
show sounds awesome and then right after
the show you're gonna sit down and look
at cards about like Wizards and and
swords and stuff and Sparkle thing I
don't know what they I don't understand
yeah but here's the deal
um I got a a great friend named Wes and
he's from the island
and he cooks incredible dishes oh yeah
you know whose house I never say no to
when they invite me to dinner
my friend West
a hundred percent of the time he's asked
me dinner I go
does he give you malasadas I don't even
know what that means but he gives me
lots of delicious things I don't even
know I don't ask as many questions so
here's the thing
if you started a weekly Dungeons and
Dragons group and you said I'm offering
food
are you are you are you married
I am okay if you told husband hey we're
gonna start putting some money in the
budget because we're gonna start having
people over and you might have to find
things to do in fact I need you to take
care of the kids because once a week I'm
putting on my uh wizard Warrior hat I
don't know what you wear to play Dragons
I'm putting on my cape and uh we're
getting weird we're gonna get super
weird up in here in this house and I'm
making some great Hawaiian food and I'm
having people over within six months you
would have a gang that would go to real
war with you not just Dungeons and
Dragons war
mm-hmm
but you have to be intentional about
creating the life that you want to have
and then there's going to come a moment
when Laura who loves who she has become
in whatever environment she is in
might want to go back to Hawaii great
or might be completely at peace just
visiting Hawaii
see what I'm saying
yes
what's holding you back from creating a
whole new world where you are
time
you got two Knuckleheads that's for sure
what else
yeah
yeah let me tell you this the greatest
the the greatest gift you can give your
kids is your presence
the second greatest gift you can give
your kids is you go be well
and you go hang out with friends
and you sit down with your husband and
say we have two little ones our marriage
is different now and I want a
rambunctious fun wild weird Dungeons and
Dragons life
I want a great sex life again I want to
be crazy and silly again I want all that
stuff again and we're gonna have to
figure out how to do that
because you keep thinking back to when I
was 18 when I was 19 and the world was
standing before me and I want to tell
you at 30 the world is still standing
right in front of you
okay
it's just a little weirder now
definitely weirder you got two kids
right
and your husband does his accounting job
or whatever he's I got who knows what
he's doing but it's just different now
but the world is still standing right in
front of you
and you get one shot you get one
opportunity and I sound like Eminem
right now you get one path that's it
you get one go
and it's easy you're at a you're at a
crossroads right now Laura that I hear
over and over and over and over you get
two kids you're married you just find
yourself doing the same thing over and
over again suddenly you're gonna blink
you're gonna be 43.
and you can either be 43 with some young
teenage kids who are always rolling
their eyes because their mom is so fun
and silly and goofy and holds them
accountable
and her and dad are always closing the
door in the middle of the afternoon and
being all weird and turning the music up
God knows what they're doing in there
because that's the kind of house we have
or you can have a husband who's a
roommate kids who are just staring at
their screens in the room you get to
choose the life you get to choose it
[Music]
you get to choose it
you are worth that choice
you're worth that choice you're worth
that choice
[Music]
it's going to be an adventure moving
forward Laura you're worth every any of
it take your husband out for breakfast
this week and said hey I talked to this
uh goofball on a podcast
and everything's about to be different
around here hope you'll join me
we'll be right back
hey good folks John deloney here I I
feel like I fell through a glitch in The
Matrix this is my job I get to have this
show do this show walk alongside each
one of you as a career this is what I do
and I have a blast doing it and me and
the team were so thankful for all of you
for being a part of our show whether
you're one of the original 17 or you're
one of the millions that's come since
then we are so grateful for you and we
want to put together the best possible
show that we can so if you're one of The
Originals or if you're brand new we want
your feedback tell us what you love
about the show what you hate about the
show would you like to see more of what
you like to hear more of and what you
want us to never do again you can email
us at askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's
askjohn ramseysolutions.com with your
feedback thank you for being such an
important part of the show rock on
all right let's go back to my hometown
home of the Houston Earth robes and talk
to Lynn in Houston what's up Lynn
hey how are you partying how are you
I'm doing good thanks for taking my call
of course thanks for calling what are
you doing what's up
um so my question is
how do I I learned to trust my husband
again and to be vulnerable in my
marriage to move forward after
discovering lies and secrets that my
husband has been keeping for years oh
gosh I'm sorry how long have y'all been
married
we've been married nine years okay
tell me tell me the secrets what's
what'd you find
so in 2020 we were refinancing our house
and I found a large debt on our debt to
wealth ratio statement
and when I questioned my husband about
it I found out that he had been hiding
about sixty thousand dollars in credit
card debt since 2016. well is he
spending that money on
he had tried to start a side business or
a construction business
um after he had gotten laid off
and uh I didn't know that he wasn't
making enough to cover his expenses and
so he was just putting things on credit
cards and not telling me about it
and interest would hit and it would get
bigger and an interest in hit get bigger
and just snowballed out of control how
long did this last
um it started in 2016.
I first found out about it in 2020
um he told me that he had it under
control he uh
gotten a line of credit he was working
to pay it off it was maybe going within
18 months it you know not to worry about
it
the next year in 2021 we tried to buy
some land and through that process I
found out that he did not have remote
control
and he was continuing to rack up more
debt
I'm calling bullcrap on the business
expense there's something else going on
here
like I I would ask for an itemized list
report of the things that were purchased
on those on those on those balance
sheets whether it's the line of credit
purchases or on the credit card
statements
sixty thousand dollars because otherwise
there'd be assets that you could see
like a truck or a tractor or a bunch of
tools
right I don't know what you would say if
he would he would move it over to a zero
interest credit card then he wouldn't
get it paid off on time and then all the
back interest was hurt I I know but
you're talking 60 000 dollars
yeah
there's something else at play is he has
he is he seeing somebody
well
not that I'm aware of at that time
but now
[Music]
he's seeing somebody now
well about six months ago I found out
that he was having a well he claimed an
emotional thing he says nothing physical
happened with a co-worker
here's why here's why you can't trust
because you know in your guts you're not
getting the full story
don't you
yes you know it you've known this dude
for more than a decade right
yeah and you know you're not getting the
full story how long
you know you're not getting the full
story
why haven't you demanded the full story
you haven't because you're scared why
well I tried I I honestly like when I
found out about this bowl
I I talk directly in your phone for me
yeah
when I found out about this girl I I
tried to demand the whole story
and like really begged for it
and
I I feel like I just maybe got the full
story of about a month ago
Maybe
I I don't know at this point I don't
know what to believe anymore
which is why I'm calling you
so
I like
he's not on the phone to defend himself
and so I can throw grenades at him all
day long I don't like to be that guy I
don't think he's telling you the truth
and I think there's something else
usually when somebody racks up this kind
of debt it's one of two things and it
does happen in construction so I want to
give that
there's usually significant assets
there's big purchases that were made
like I'm starting a construction company
or a long company there in Houston I got
to get the biggest dually truck whatever
and the nicest mowers but they're stuff
right stuff that we can go sell or that
it's hard to hide because it's sitting
right here
right there's that
or there's somebody buying hotel rooms
and purses and small trips for other
people on a credit card
and that happens and you don't get
caught and then it happens again and you
don't get caught and it happens again
and suddenly you're running
um some businessy debt-ish sort of-ish
and you're running some personal life
stuff and we're going to the baseball
game and we're doing some stuff and I'm
gonna be out later I can't come home
this weekend or we're going to this
thing over the weekend the jobs got
crazy so I'm just getting a hotel and
I'll be here tonight and those things
happen year after year after year and
all of a sudden somebody goes to get a
loan for a small thing and it's huge
I hope beyond all hope I'm wrong on that
okay
I hope I'm wrong
but something tells me you know you
haven't got the full story on that money
and something tells me you haven't
trusted him for a long long time so the
only person I can I can
say anything to it's you because you're
on the phone
and so I'm gonna ask you like a super
direct question what do you need to see
with your own eyes
so that you can exhale because you
haven't exhaled in months and months and
months if not years
is it text messages is it bank
statements what do you need to see
yeah I mean honestly I've been
divorced why why
I don't know I guess because I found the
Ramsey plant there was like there was a
there was a plan to fix it there was a
path
you know but it but he was never up and
up about the dishonesty
I'm sorry he was never up and up about
the dishonesty
like okay so you've got the money thing
you've got the emotional affair with the
co-worker and
that's not right it happens all the time
right so I mean it's a oh it's it's not
a deal breaker in a relationship it's
not a it's not a marriage deal breaker
it's not a dating deal breaker those
things happen we sit down we work
through them
um and we figured them out okay so I'm
not minimizing that at all but also you
would not be calling me and saying is
this thing over how do I come back from
this if it was just that if it was just
a few months he was close to somebody at
work they shared a few laughs they got
they exchanged texts and they probably
shouldn't exchange started hiding stuff
um
like that wouldn't lead to this
so there's something else going on what
else do you feel he's not honest with
you about fully
well I mean a few weeks ago
or I guess about a month ago we came to
Austin for real smart conference
and he's been doing
um a bunch of side work to help pay off
all this debt and so he's been working a
lot in a single woman's home
and so I got insecure and was asking
questions about their relationship and
you know is she attractive and those
kinds of things
and then not two days later I find
deleted text messages between them where
he had taken my insecurities and shared
them with her
that sucks
was it in a mocking way kind of making
fun of you a little bit or or were
getting caught
was well I mean
I mean it's her text message that said
something along the lines of like you
know thinking about your wife's
questions I I would never you're an
honest family man I would never you know
interrupt your precious family
and so apparently he told her that like
when we were in Austin
she came up and I started asking how if
she was pretty and you know according to
him he just wanted to make sure that the
professional lines were there which is
BS but that's the story you know that's
not true
yes I do
okay but that's all I'm able to get
up so do you just gonna settle
I don't know
I think we really dealt with
and so there's just a lot of layers yeah
did he ever agree to go to marriage
counseling with you
we have our second session on Thursday
okay what was the first session like
just introductory
yeah okay
here's what I would do if I was you like
I'm just trying to fast forward myself
and like pick myself up and put myself
in your shoes
and I'm with somebody that I built a
life with I'm with somebody that I love
they've been at this point how old are
you
37 okay you've known him longer than you
haven't known him right
yeah like he's one of your arms and one
of your legs at this point
and so it's hard to face the truth about
that
but here we are
and I would write down I would spend a
couple of days writing down where are
the things if I go back over the last 5
or 10 or 15 years where are the things
that something came up and my first
thought was that's not right
but I just blew it off
I just passed it over
I didn't dig it any further
I want you to write those things down
and here's the key
he opened the door
with his financial infidelity and I'm
using that word intentionally
he was deceitful he cheated on you with
money and it impacts you because your
name is on all the things
and it impacted your refi it impacted
this dream of owning land that you had
and then he told you he had another plan
he was working on it and you come to
find out he not only lied about having a
plan he dug the hole deeper
and then he had an emotional affair with
somebody at work
and then you went with your intuition
you trusted that gut your that voice in
your gut and you called him out on
somebody at work uh some woman's house
he's working in
and he clearly had some sort of
secondary conversation with her that
seemed strange and off book and he
wanted to make sure you didn't see it
and those are just a few you've told me
about in these five minutes
and I want you to write those things
down and when you sit down with a
therapist I want you to say
I can't go forward in this marriage
until I get some truthful answers and I
don't feel like you've been telling me
the truth for a long long time
because you and him can come up with all
the new conversation strategies and
communication strategy and all this
stuff but you are you don't feel like
the ground underneath you is solid right
I can hear it in your voice you think
you're crazy
you're not crazy
you've been moved around and shuffled
and kind of pushed to the side here you
kind of been treated like you're dumb
for a long time
she's too dumb
and I don't think you're dumb
is that fair
and here man I will say this I'll I'll
preacher he can call me I'd love to have
him on the show
and if I'm wrong about every step of the
way if he just found himself in a scary
deep shameful hole when it came to money
and he just kept digging and the hole
kept getting bigger I've sat with those
guys and that happens that's true
and he hated who he'd become he was
ashamed of himself and then he found
somebody at work that laughed at his
jokes and suddenly he's sharing stuff
and confiding in somebody else it's not
his wife because his wife is a call back
to how that happens that those two
things happen it happened with some
regularity and I'm not going to beat
somebody up for those moments but we got
to take some radical action to change
him
but what you're telling me is something
that sounds different
Fair
yes
why are there tears coming
because I mean that's exactly how I feel
I mean I feel like he just thinks that
I'm stupid and that he can just keep
you know
getting away with things but then also I
know that like
there when I got diagnosed there was
like a big shift in our relationship
you know why he thinks that
you can get away with things
why does he think that one
because he did for so long I guess I
don't know yeah because he can
because he can
and he'll just delete the messages and
when you find the deleted messages he'll
call you crazy and you're nuts and then
you're exhausted you got two kids and
the thought of anything
disruptive at this point is just too
it's just too much and so
I guess I'm just crazy I'm just gonna go
into the next day
and first it was the refi and then it
was the trip to Austin then it was the
hey let's buy some land and it's just
going to keep coming up and coming up
and coming up
at some point someone's got to turn the
lights on turn off the music and say the
dance is over
I need to know some the truth
we gotta be adults we gotta talk we
gotta be honest let's just get this all
out of here
so if I'm you
thankfully he agreed to go to marriage
counseling
hopefully it's not just a perfunctory
deal to get you off his back hopefully
he's actually interested in healing this
marriage
I would say those that the things you've
just told me here's the things that over
the course of our marriage feel like
you're not telling me the truth and
you've made me feel crazy for called
throwing a flag on them I've got to know
the truth
and it may be that I want to see all the
financial records I want to see every
expenditure
all of them
and maybe I want to get every single
text message you've sent and all the
emails and all of this the WhatsApp and
all the signal I wanted to get all the
conversation
and also when I got diagnosed you
started treating me differently now I
feel less than
let's get to the bottom of it let me
just say this I don't think you're crazy
Lynn
I think you've ignored that voice in
your chest for so long
and now she's screaming at you we're not
safe we're not safe we're not safe we're
not safe maybe for the first time in a
long time let's listen to that voice
let me know how the uh triple the cut to
the conversation with the counselor goes
and I'll walk with you every step of the
way thanks for your call thanks for
being brave we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right as we wrap up today's show
listen
here's like The Meta theme of today's
show
trust yourself
something feels sideways if something
feels off
you're probably not crazy and if you've
had some seasons in the past when you
trusted yourself and you kind of threw a
fit about things and you were off
um call a trusted friend and just
pretend you're talking to me and just
rattle some things off in a row
they may look at you and say uh have you
heard what you've said and they may be
right
most of you aren't as dumb as people
treat you
all right as we wrap up today's show um
listen this is my my
call
Mark Slaughter you live in my
neighborhood you live here in Tennessee
in Asheville Franklin
come be on my show man you're one of my
one of my heroes please
I will make sure Kelly is at arm's
distance from you at all times
um I'll sit behind the glass I'm good
I'll sit here on the other side of the
glass please come be on our show
um
I loved your your band growing up you're
one of my faves and now you're one of my
neighbors so let's do this let's do this
Mark Slaughter all right the song one of
the greatest songs ever written ever
from the great band Slaughter and the
song is called Flight of the angels and
it goes like this
pictures of you ah they're still on my
mind
you had this smile that could light up
the world
now when it rains it seems the Sun never
shines and I drive down this lonely
lonely road
I got this feeling girl that I gotta let
you go
because now you've got to fly high fly
to the angels heaven awaits your heart
and flowers bloom in your name you know
how often I use that line Mark oh that's
incredible
flowers bloom in your name come on man
that's just fantastic you gotta fly to
the angels and all the stars in the
night shine in your name
[Music]
they don't write poetry like that
anymore ladies and gentlemen hey we'll
see you soon stay in school don't do
drugs
[Music]